update on some wild [ __ ] apparently asap
cheated on rihanna
[Music]
it's a spring while she's pregnant with
this [ __ ] child does it
surprise us with a fenty footwear model
you like them toes
[Laughter]
if that's true
we don't know the ins and outs and the
dynamics of their relationship they
could have an open relationship well no
because cheating specifically means
but who said it was cheating did rihanna
say it was cheating regardless she's
pregnant
i feel like and he's not getting any sex
so he's going to hold off
nine months
six men
again y'all are i swear to god y'all are
animals
oh yes that's what it's been saying
y'all y'all really just like to play up
the primal instinct man well because
like it comes from somewhere jessica
like yeah like plenty of guys that do
have self-control and can hold
themselves
for a um greater cause maybe they got a
boxing match or they decide to become a
monk no because they just don't feel
like they have to function off of sex
you don't understand men that's a
problem you don't understand then you
don't understand men that's the problem
um so i don't understand the men that i
interact with on a daily basis but you
understand them better yes because i'm a
man yeah because they're they're guys
jessica babes it's really sad that you
all generalize them right now but you
know men have very general things that
we all kind of tick the boxes on okay we
do okay i'm not saying that it's right
for if that's true if asap rocky cheated
on it rihanna i'm not saying it's right
i'm not saying that's right i'm saying
men are very
sexually wired creatures
they are and
i understand because i i was with my
son's mum for 10 years and when she was
pregnant
i didn't have sex with her for like
seven months
do you know what i mean but was i
looking at
the most random
woman on the street thinking oh yeah
because
th the the that's where you can only
speak for yourself though no but i'm
saying that
wasn't getting me if that makes sense
and there's a primal instinct why is it
that any products advertised to men
they've got to put a um sexy lady on
there right like they understand men's
biology they don't have psychology they
do
the problem is i think nowadays is that
women want men to be like women
and we're just not and so you you we
can't be like
it's a double-edged sword if we become
like women you despise us that's correct
you're like oh that guy's too soft oh
look at that guy oh he's a simple
you don't like men being like women
except for you
by the way um
yeah we don't like so funny every time
he says something like wild to me he's
like well it's more like it's more like
i think your reaction is just like very
pissed off and i'm trying like so no i
just
can't laugh
it's what we call banter over here but
that doesn't mean that it's funny yeah
but also
right where you actually might not be
funny almost guaranteed very true your
perspective now will be totally
different another five years time yes
great yeah yeah okay well guess what
we're not talking five years from now
we're talking right now so i'm going to
speak for myself right now
okay so right now you don't understand
men and how they think and what their
psychology is and you don't understand
women that and that's fair enough
there we go now
look at that we agreed on something okay
but the thing is when you were speaking
is that you when you were speaking out i
was understanding of myself and anyone's
understanding that you don't understand
how men think
and that that's that's what i'm pointing
out i'm not trying to say that you're a
bad person or anything i'm just saying
when it comes to men and the way in
which we think and feel women generally
don't understand how men think and feel
and they try to make men into women i
know i just wish that sometimes with
these people doing all this transgender
stuff maybe they could do a trans
mind stuff so i'll put a girl into a
boy's mind and find out what we go
through like literally we think of sex
too you know
yeah men think of sex a lot yeah